(dramatic music)
- [Female Narrator] Robert
Johnson is considered
one of the greatest blues
artists of all time.
- [Male Narrator] It's the template
for what become rock and roll.
- [Male] I believe Robert
Johnson was extremely talented,
extremely gifted, and way off balance.
Something's spinning
strangely in that man's life.
Robert was a novice guitar
player, not very good.
- [Man] This man was a nobody.
And then he disappears.
A year and a half later, he's
doing things with a guitar
that even his mentors can't do.
- [Narrator] How could
Robert possibly have gotten
that good that fast?
(dramatic music)
- [Male Narrator] The
myth goes that Robert
went to the crossroads,
got down on his knees,
handed his guitar to the devil.
The devil said, once you
receive the guitar back,
your soul is mine.
- [Man] If you do make
a deal with the devil,
you're gonna have to pay the price.
- [Narrator] It ended up costing
him, the bill coming due.
- [Male] He let his arrogance go too far.
- [Guy] We all have to choose
how much we can sacrifice in
order to achieve greatness.
(blues guitar music)